ALAN WINFIELD: Thank
you very much indeed.
It's really great to be here.
And thank you so much
for the invitation.
So yes, robot intelligence.
So I've titled the lecture
"The Thinking Robot."
But of course, that
immediately begs the question,
what on earth do we
mean by thinking?
Well we could, of
course, spend the whole
of the next hour debating
what we mean by thinking.
But I should say that I'm
particularly interested in
and will focus on
embodied intelligence.
So in other words, the kind
of intelligence that we have,
that animals including humans
have, and that robots have.
So of course that
slightly differentiates
what I'm talking about from AI.
But I regard robotics as
a kind of subset of AI.
And of course one of the
things that we discovered
in the last 60 odd years
of artificial intelligence
is that the things that we
thought were really difficult
actually are relatively easy.
Like playing chess, or
go, for that matter.
Whereas the things that
we originally thought
were really easy, like making
a cup of tea, are really hard.
So it's kind of the opposite
of what was expected.
So embodied intelligence
in the real world
is really very difficult indeed.
And that's what
I'm interested in.
So this is the
outline of the talk.
I'm going to talk initially
about intelligence
and offer some
ideas, if you like,
for a way of thinking
about intelligence
and breaking it
down into categories
or types of intelligence.
And then I'm going to choose
a particular one which
I've been really working on
the last three or four years.
And it's what I call
a generic architecture
for a functional imagination.
Or in short, robots
with internal models.
So that's really what
I want to focus on.
Because I really
wanted to show you
some experimental
work that we've
done the last couple
of years in the lab.
I mean, I'm an
electronics engineer.
I'm an experimentalist.
And so doing experiments
is really important for me.
So the first thing that
we ought to realize--
I'm sure we do realize-- is that
intelligence is not one thing
that we all, animals,
humans, and robots
have more or less of.
Absolutely not.
And you know, there are several
ways of breaking intelligence
down into different
kind of categories,
if you like, of
intelligence, different types
of intelligence.
And here's one that I came
up with in the last couple
of years.
It's certainly not the only way
of thinking about intelligence.
But this really breaks
intelligence into four,
if you like, types, four
kinds of intelligence.
You could say kinds
of minds, I guess.
The most fundamental
is what we call
morphological intelligence.
And that's the intelligence
that you get just
from having a physical body.
And there are some
interesting questions
about how you design
morphological intelligence.
You've probably all seen
pictures of or movies of robots
that can walk, but in
fact don't actually
have any computing, any
computation whatsoever.
In other words, the
behavior of walking
is an emergent property
of the mechanics,
if you like, the springs and
levers and so on in the robot.
So that's an example of
morphological intelligence.
Individual intelligence is
the kind of intelligence
that you get from
learning individually.
Social intelligence,
I think, is really
interesting and important.
And that's the
one that I'm going
to focus on most in this talk.
Social intelligence
is the intelligence
that you get from learning
socially, from each other.
And of course, we
are a social species.
And the other one
which I've been
working on a lot in
the last 20 odd years
is swarm intelligence.
So this is the kind
of intelligence
that we see most particularly
in social animals, insects.
The most interesting properties
of swarm intelligence
tend to be emergent
or self-organizing.
So in other words,
the intelligence
is typically manifest as
a collective behavior that
emerges from the, if you
like, the micro interactions
between the individuals
in that population.
So emergence and
self-organization
are particularly
interesting to me.
But I said this is
absolutely not the only way
to think about intelligence.
And I'm going to
show you another way
of thinking about intelligence
which I particularly like.
And this is Dan Dennett's
tower of generate and test.
So in Darwin's Dangerous
Idea, and several other books,
I think, Dan Dennett
suggests that a good way
of thinking about intelligence
is to think about the fact
that all animals,
including ourselves, need
to decide what actions to take.
So choosing the next action is
really critically important.
I mean it's critically important
for all of us, including
humans.
Even though the wrong
action may not kill us,
as it were, for humans.
But for many animals,
the wrong action
may well kill that animal.
And Dennett talks
about what he calls
the tower of generate and test
which I want to show you here.
It's a really cool
breakdown, if you like, way
of thinking about intelligence.
So at the bottom of his tower
are Darwinian creatures.
And the thing about
Darwinian creatures
is that they have
only one way of,
as it were, learning
from, if you like,
generating and testing
next possible actions.
And that is natural selection.
So Darwinian creatures in
his schema cannot learn.
They can only try out an action.
If it kills them, well
that's the end of that.
So by the laws of
natural selection,
that particular action
is unlikely to be
passed on to descendants.
Now, of course, all
animals on the planet
are Darwinian creatures,
including ourselves.
But a subset of what Dennett
calls Skinnerian creatures.
So Skinnerian creatures
are able to generate
a next possible candidate
action, if you like,
a next possible
action and try it out.
And here's the thing,
if it doesn't kill them
but it's actually a bad action,
then they'll learn from that.
Or even if it's a good
action, a Skinnerian creature
will learn from
trying out an action.
So really, Skinnerian creatures
are a subset of Darwinians,
actually a small subset
that are able to learn
by trial and error, individually
learn by trial and error.
Now, the third layer,
or story, if you
like, in Dennett's tower, he
calls Popperian creatures,
after, obviously, the
philosopher, Karl Popper.
And Popperian creatures
have a big advantage
over Darwinians and
Skinnerians in that they
have an internal model of
themselves in the world.
And with an internal
model, it means
that you can try out
an action, a candidate
next possible action, if
you like, by imagining it.
And it means that you
don't have to actually have
to put yourself to the
risk of trying it out
for real physically
in the world,
and possibly it killing you,
or at least harming you.
So Popperian creatures have
this amazing invention,
which is internal modeling.
And of course, we are examples
of Popperian creatures.
But there are plenty of
other animals-- again,
it's not a huge proportion.
It's rather a small proportion,
in fact, of all animals.
But certainly there
are plenty of animals
that are capable in some
form of modeling their world
and, as it were, imagining
actions before trying them out.
And just to complete
Dennett's tower,
he adds another layer that
he calls Gregorian creatures.
Here's he's naming this
layer after Richard Gregory,
the British psychologist.
And the thing that
Gregorian creatures have
is that in addition
to internal models,
they have mind tools like
language and mathematics.
Especially language because it
means that Gregorian creatures
can share their experiences.
In fact, a Gregorian
creature could, for instance,
model in its brain, in its
mind, the possible consequences
of doing a particular thing,
and then actually pass
that knowledge to you.
So you don't even have
to model it yourself.
So the Gregorian
creatures really
have the kind of
social intelligence
that we probably--
perhaps not uniquely,
but there are obviously
only a handful
of species that are able to
communicate, if you like,
traditions with each other.
So I think internal models are
really, really interesting.
And as I say, I've been
spending the last couple
of years thinking about
robots with internal models.
And actually doing
experiments with
robots with internal models.
So are robots with
internal models self-aware?
Well probably not in the
sense that-- the everyday
sense that we mean by
self-aware, sentient.
But certainly internal
models, I think,
can provide a
minimal level of kind
of functional self-awareness.
And absolutely enough to allow
us to ask what if questions.
So with internal models, we have
potentially a really powerful
technique for robots.
Because it means that
they can actually ask
themselves questions
about what if I take this
or that next possible action.
So there's the action
selection, if you like.
So really, I'm kind of
following Dennett's model.
I'm really interested in
building Popperian creatures.
Actually, I'm interested in
building Gregorian creatures.
But that's another, if you
like, another step in the story.
So really, here I'm
focusing primarily
on Popperian creatures.
So robots with internal models.
And what I'm talking
about in particular
is a robot with a
simulation of itself
and it's currently perceived
environment and of the actors
inside itself.
So it takes a bit of
getting your head around.
The idea of a robot with
a simulation of itself
inside itself.
But that's really what
I'm talking about.
And the famous, the late
John Holland, for instance,
rather perceptively
wrote an internal model
that allows a
system to look ahead
to the future
consequences of actions
without committing
itself to those actions.
I don't know
whether John Holland
was aware of Dennett's tower.
Possibly not.
But really saying the same
kind of thing as Dan Dennett.
Now before I come on to the
work that I've been doing,
I want to show you some
examples of-- a few examples,
there aren't many, in fact--
of robots with self-simulation.
The first one, as
far as I'm aware,
was by Richard
Vaughan and his team.
And he used a simulation
inside a robot
to allow it to plan a safe
route with incomplete knowledge.
So as far as I'm aware, this
is the world's first example
of robots with self-simulation.
Perhaps an example that you
might already be familiar with,
this is Josh Bongard
and Hod Lipson's work.
Very notable, very
interesting work.
Here, self-simulation, but
for a different purpose.
So this is not
self-simulation to choose,
as it were, gross
actions in the world.
But instead,
self-simulation to learn
how to control your own body.
So that the idea here is that
if you have a complex body, then
a self-simulation is a really
good way of figuring out
how to control
yourself, including
how to repair yourself
if parts of you
should break or fail or
be damaged, for instance.
So that's a really
interesting example
of what you can do
with self-simulation.
And a similar idea,
really, was tested
by my old friend, Owen Holland.
He built this kind of
scary looking robot.
Initially it was called
Chronos, but but then it
became known as ECCE-robot.
And this robot is deliberately
designed to be hard to control.
In fact, Owen refers to
it as anthropomimetic.
Which means anthropic
from the inside out.
So most humanoid robots are
only humanoid on the outside.
But here, we have a robot
that has a skeletal structure,
it has tendons,
it's very-- and you
can see from the
little movie clip
there, if any part
of the robot moves,
then the whole of
the rest of the robot
tends to flex, rather like
human bodies or animal bodies.
So Owen was particularly
interested in a robot
that is difficult to control.
And the idea then of using an
internal simulation of yourself
in order to be able to
control yourself or learn
to control yourself.
And he was the first to
come up with this phrase,
functional imagination.
Really interesting work,
so do check that out.
And the final example
I want to give
you is from my own lab,
where-- this is swarm robotics
work-- where in fact we're doing
evolutionary swarm robotics
here.
And we've put a simulation
of each robot and the swarm
inside each robot.
And in fact, we're using
those internal simulations
as part of a genetic algorithm.
So each robot, in fact, is
evolving its own controller.
And in fact, it actually
updates its own controller
about once a second.
So again, it's a bit an odd
thing to get your head around.
So about once a
second, each robot
becomes its own great, great,
great, great grandchild.
In other words, its
controller is a descendant.
But the problem with this is
that the internal simulation
tends to be wrong.
And we have what we
call the reality gap.
So the gap between the
simulation and the real world.
And so we got round that-- my
student Paul O'Dowd came up
with the idea that
we could co-evolve
the simulators, as well as
the controllers in the robots.
So we have a
population of robots
inside each individual
physical robot, as it were,
simulated robots.
But then you also have
a swarm of 10 robots.
And therefore, we have a
population of 10 simulators.
So we actually co-evolve
here, the simulators
and the robot controllers.
So I want to now
show you the newer
work I've been doing on
robots with internal models.
And primarily-- I was
telling [? Yan ?] earlier
that, you know, I'm kind of
an old fashioned electronics
engineer.
Spent much of my career
building safety systems,
safety critical systems.
So safety is something
that's very important to me
and to robotics.
So here's a kind of
generic internal modeling
architecture for safety.
So this is, in fact, Dennett's
loop of generate and test.
So the idea is that we have
an internal model, which
is a self-simulation, that
is initialized to match
the current real world.
And then you try out,
you run the simulator
for each of your next
possible actions.
To put it very simply,
imagine that you're a robot,
and you could either turn left,
turn right, go straight ahead,
or stand still.
So you have four
possible next actions.
And therefore, you'd loop
through this internal model
for each of those
next possible actions.
And then moderate the
action selection mechanism
in your controller.
So this is not part
of the controller.
It's a kind of
moderator, if you like.
So you could imagine
that the regular robot
controller, the thing in
red, has a set of four
next possible actions.
But your internal
model determines
that only two of them are safe.
So it would effectively,
if you like,
moderate or govern the
action selection mechanism
of the robot's controller,
so that the robot
controller, in fact, will not
choose the unsafe actions.
Interestingly, if you have
a learning controller,
then that's fine because we
can effectively extend or copy
the learned behaviors
into the internal model.
That's fine.
So in principle-- we
haven't done this.
But we're starting to do
it now-- in principle,
we can extend this architecture
to, as it were, to adaptive
or learning robots.
Here's a simple
thought experiment.
Imagine a robot with several
safety hazards facing it.
It has four next
possible actions.
Well, your internal
model can figure out
what the consequence of each
of those actions might be.
So two of them-- so either
turn right or stay still
are safe actions.
So that's a very simple
thought experiment.
And here's a slightly more
complicated thought experiment.
So imagine that
the robot, there's
another actor in
the environment.
It's a human.
The human is not looking
where they're going.
Perhaps walking down the
street peering at a smartphone.
That never happens,
does it, of course.
And about to walk into
a hole in the pavement.
Well, of course, if
it were you noticing
that human about to walk
into a hole in the pavement,
you would almost certainly
intervene, of course.
And it's not just because
you're a good person.
It's because you have
the cognitive machinery
to predict the consequences of
both your and their actions.
And you can figure
out that if you
were to rush over
towards them, you
might be able to prevent them
from falling into the hole.
So here's the same kind of idea.
But with the robot.
Imagine it's not
you, but a robot.
And imagine now that
you are modeling
the consequences of
yours and the human's
actions for each one of
your next possible actions.
And you can see
that now this time,
we've given a kind
of numerical scale.
So 0 is perfectly safe, whereas
10 is seriously dangerous,
kind of danger of
death, if you like.
And you can see that
the safest outcome
is if the robot turns right.
In other words, the
safest for the human.
I mean, clearly the
safest for the robot
is either turn
left or stay still.
But in both cases, the human
would fall into the hole.
So you can see that
we could actually
invent a rule which
would represent
the best outcome for the human.
And this is what it looks like.
So if all robot actions,
the human is equally safe,
then that means that we don't
need to worry about the human,
so the internal model will
output the safest actions
for the robot.
Else, then output
the robot actions
for the least unsafe
human outcomes.
Now remarkably-- and
we didn't intend this,
this actually is
an implementation
of Asimov's first
law of robotics.
So a robot may not
injure a human being,
or through inaction--
that's important,
the or through inaction-- allow
a human being to come to harm.
So we kind of ended up
building Asimovian robot,
simple Asimovian ethical robot.
So what does it look like?
Well, we've now extended
to humanoid robots.
But we started with
the e-puck robots,
these little-- they're about
the size of a salt shaker,
I guess, about seven
centimeters tall.
And this is the little
arena in the lab.
And what we actually have
inside the ethical robot is--
this is the internal
architecture.
So so you can see that we have
the robot controller, which
is, in fact, a mirror of
the real robot controller,
a model of the robot, and
a model of the world, which
includes others in the world.
So this is the simulator.
This is a more or less a
regular robot simulator.
So you probably know
that robot simulators
are quite commonplace.
We roboticists use them all
the time to test robots in,
as it were, in
the virtual world,
before then trying
out the code for real.
But what we've done
here is we've actually
put an off the shelf
simulator inside the robot
and made it work in real time.
So the output of the
simulator for each
of those next possible actions
is evaluated and then goes
through a logic layer.
Which is essentially the
rule, the if then else rule
that I showed you a
couple of slides ago.
And that effectively
determines or moderates
the action selection
mechanism of the real robot.
So this is the
simulation budget.
So we're actually using
the open source simulator
Stage, a well-known simulator.
And in fact, we managed to get
Stage to run about 600 times
real time.
Which means that
we're actually cycling
through our internal
model twice a second.
And for each one
of those cycles,
we're actually modeling not four
but 30 next possible actions.
And we're modeling about
10 seconds into the future.
So every half a second, our
robot with an internal model
is looking ahead 10 seconds for
about 30 next possible actions,
30 of its own next
possible actions.
But of course, it's also
modeling the consequences
of each of the other
actors, dynamic actors
in its environment.
So this is quite nice to
actually do this in real time.
And let me show you some of the
results that we got from that.
So ignore the kind
of football pitch.
So what we have here is
the ethical robot, which we
call the A-robot, after Asimov.
And we have a hole
in the ground.
It's not a real hole, it's a
virtual hole in the ground.
We don't need to be digging
holes into the lab floor.
And we're using another
e-perk as a proxy human
we call this the H-robot.
So let me show
you what happened.
Well we ran it, first of
all, with no H-robot at all,
as a kind of baseline.
And you can see on
the left, in 26 runs,
those are the traces
of the A-robot.
So you can see the
A-robot, in fact,
is maintaining its own safety.
Its avoiding, its
skirting around the edge
almost optimally skirting the
edge of the hole in the ground.
But then when we
introduce the H-robot,
you get this wonderful
behavior here.
Where as soon as the A-robot
notices that the H-robot is
heading towards the hole,
which is about here, then
it deflects, it diverts
from its original course.
And in fact, more
or less collides.
They don't actually
physically collide
because they have low
level collision avoidance.
So they don't actually collide.
But nevertheless, the
A-robot effectively
heads off the H-robot, but
then bounces off safely,
goes off in another direction.
And the A-robot then resumes its
course to its target position.
Which is really nice.
And interestingly, even though
our simulator is rather low
fidelity, it doesn't matter.
Surprisingly, it doesn't matter.
Because the closer the
A-robot to the H-robot
gets, then the better its
predictions about colliding.
So this is why, even with a
rather low fidelity simulator,
we can collide with really good
precision with the H-robot.
So let me show you the movies of
this trial with a single proxy
human.
And I think the movie starts
in-- so this is real time.
And you can see the
A-robot nicely heading off
the H-robot which
then disappears off
towards the left.
I think then we've
speeded it four times.
And this is a
whole load of runs.
So you can see that
it really does work.
And also notice that every
experiment is a bit different.
And of course, that's what
typically happens when
you have real physical robots.
Simply because of the
noise in the system,
the fact that these are real
robots with imperfect motors
and sensors and what have you.
So we wrote the paper
and were about to submit
the paper, when we
kind of thought, well,
this is a bit boring, isn't it?
We built this
robot and it works.
So we had the idea to put a
second human in the-- oh sorry.
I've forgotten one slide.
So before I get to
that, I just wanted
to show you a little animation
of-- these little filaments
here are the traces of the
A-robot and its prediction
of what might happen.
So at the point
where this turns red,
the A-robot then
starts to intersect.
And each one of those
traces is its prediction
of the consequences of both
itself and the H-robot.
This is really nice because you
can kind of look into the mind,
to put it that
way, of the robot,
and actually see
what it's doing.
Which is very nice, very cool.
But I was about to say we tried
the same experiment, in fact,
identical code,
with two H-robots.
And this is the robot's dilemma.
This may be the first time
that a real physical robot
has faced an ethical dilemma.
So you can see the two
H-robots are more or less
equidistant from the hole.
And there is the
A-robot which, in fact,
fails to save either of them.
So what's going on there?
We know that it can save
one of them every time.
But in fact, it's just
failed to save either.
And oh, yeah, it does
actually save one of them.
And has a look at the other
one, but it's too late.
So this is really
very interesting.
And not at all what we expected.
In fact, let me show
you the statistics.
So in 33 runs, the
ethical robot failed
to save either of the H-robots
just under half the time.
So about 14 times, it
failed to save either.
It saved one of them just
over 15, perhaps 16 times.
And amazingly, saved
both of them twice,
which is quite surprising.
It really should perform
better than that.
And in fact, when we started
to really look at this,
we discovered that
the-- so here's
a particularly good
example of dithering.
So we realized
that we made a sort
of pathologically
indecisive ethical robot.
So I'm going to save this
one-- oh no, no, that
one-- oh no, no,
this one-- that one.
And of course, by the
time our ethical robot
has changed its mind
three or four times,
well, it's too late.
So this is the problem.
The problem, fundamentally,
is that our ethical robot
doesn't make a decision
and stick to it.
In fact, it's a
consequence of the fact
that we are running
our consequence engine,
as I mentioned, twice a second.
So every half a second,
our ethical robot
has the opportunity
to change its mind.
That's clearly a bad strategy.
But nevertheless, it
was an interesting kind
of unexpected consequence
of the experiment.
We've now transferred the
work to these humanoid robots.
And we get the same thing.
So here, there
are two red robots
both heading toward danger.
The blue one, the ethical
robot, changes its mind,
and goes and saves
the one on the left,
even though it could have
saved the one on the right.
So another example of our
dithering ethical robot.
And as I've just
hinted at, the reason
that there our ethical
robot is so indecisive
is because it's essentially
a memory-less architecture.
So you could say that the
robot has a-- again, borrowing
Owen Holland's description, it
has a functional imagination.
But it has no
autobiographical memory.
So it doesn't
remember the decision
it made half a second ago.
Which is clearly
not a good strategy.
Really, an ethical
robot, just like you
if you are acting in
a similar situation,
it's probably a
good idea for you
to stick to the first
decision that you made.
But probably not forever.
So you know, I think
the decisions probably
need to be sticky somehow.
So decisions like this
may need a half life.
You know, sticky but not
but not absolutely rigid.
So actually, at this
point, we decided
that we're not going to worry
too much about this problem.
Because in a sense, this is
more of a problem for ethicists
than engineers, perhaps.
I don't know.
But maybe we could
talk about that.
Before finishing,
I want to show you
another experiment that we did
with the same architecture,
exactly the same architecture.
And this is what we call
the corridor experiment.
So here we have a robot
with this internal model.
And it has to get from the
left hand to the right hand
of a crowded corridor
without bumping
into any of the other robots
that are in the same corridor.
So imagine you're walking
down a corridor in an airport
and everybody else is coming
in the opposite direction.
And you want to try and get to
the other end of the corridor
without crashing
into any of them.
But in fact, you have a
rather large body space.
You don't want to get
even close to any of them.
So you want to maintain
your private body space.
And what the blue
robot here is doing
is, in fact, modeling the
consequences of its actions
and the other ones within
this radius of attention.
So this blue circle is
a radius of attention.
So here, we're looking at a
simple attention mechanism.
Which is only worry about
the other dynamic actors
within your radius of attention.
In fact, we don't even worry
about ones that are behind us.
It's only the ones that are
more or less in front of us.
And you can see that the
robot does eventually make it
to the end of the corridor.
But with lots of kind
of stops and back tracks
in order to prevent it
from-- because it's really
frightened of any kind of
contact with the other robots.
And here, we're not
showing all of the sort
of filaments of prediction.
Only the ones that are chosen.
And here are some results
which interestingly show us--
so perhaps the best one to
look at is this danger ratio.
And dumb simply means robots
with no internal model at all.
And intelligent means
robots with internal models.
So here, the danger ratio
is the number of times
that you actually come
close to another robot.
And of course it's very high.
This is simulated
in real robots.
Very good correlation between
the real and simulated.
And with the intelligent
robot, the robot
with the internal model, we
get a really very much safer
performance.
Clearly there is some
cost in the sense
that, for instance,
the intelligent robot
runs with internal models
tend to cover more ground.
But surprisingly, not that
much further distance.
It's less than you'd expect.
And clearly, there's
a computational cost.
Because the computational
cost of simulating clearly
is zero for the dumb robots,
whereas it's quite high for
the intelligent robot, the
robot with internal models.
But again, computation is
relatively free these days.
So actually, we're
trading safety
for computation, which I
think is a good trade off.
So really, I want
to conclude there.
I've not, of course,
talked about all aspects
of robot intelligence.
That would be a
three hour seminar.
And even then, I wouldn't
be able to cover it all.
But what I hope I've shown
you in the last few minutes
is that with internal
models, we have
a very powerful generic
architecture which we could
call a functional imagination.
And this is where I'm being
a little bit speculative.
Perhaps this moves
us in the direction
of artificial theory of mind,
perhaps even self-awareness.
I'm not going to use the
word machine consciousness.
Well, I just have.
But that's a very much more
difficult goal, I think.
And I think there
is practical value,
I think there's real practical
value in robotics of robots
with self and other simulation.
Because as I hope
I've demonstrated,
at least in a kind of prototype
sense, proof of concept,
that such simulation moves
us towards safer and possibly
ethical systems in
unpredictable environments
with other dynamic actors.
So thank you very much
indeed for listening.
I'd obviously be delighted
to take any questions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
HOST: Thank you very much for
this very fascinating view
on robotics today.
We have time for questions.
Please wait until you've
got a microphone so we have
the answer also on the video.
AUDIENCE: The game playing
computers-- or perhaps more
accurately would be saying
game playing algorithms,
predated the examples
you listed as computers
with internal models.
Still, you didn't mention those.
Is there a particular
reason why you didn't?
ALAN WINFIELD: I guess I
should have mentioned them.
You're quite right.
I mean, the-- what
I'm thinking of here
is particularly robots
with explicit simulations
of themselves and the world.
So I was limiting my examples
to simulations of themselves
in the world.
I mean, you're quite
right that of course
game-playing algorithms need to
have a simulation of the game.
And quite likely,
of the-- in fact,
certainly, of the possible
moves of the opponent,
as well as the game-playing
AI's own moves.
So you're quite right.
I mean, it's a different
kind of simulation.
But I should include that.
You're right.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
In your simulation, you had
the H-robot with one goal,
and the A-robot with
a different goal.
And they interacted
with each other halfway
through the goals.
What happens when they
have the same goal?
ALAN WINFIELD: The same goal.
AUDIENCE: Reaching the
same spot, for example.
ALAN WINFIELD: I don't
know is the short answer.
It depends on whether that
spot is a safe spot or not.
I mean, if it's a safe spot,
then they'll both go toward it.
They'll both reach it,
but without crashing
into each other.
Because the A-robot
will make sure
that it avoids the H-robot.
In fact, that's
more or less what's
happening in the
corridor experiment.
That's right.
Yeah.
But it's a good question,
we should try that.
AUDIENCE: The
simulation that you
did for the corridor experiment,
the actual real world
experiment, the simulation
track the other robots
movements as well?
Meaning what information
did the simulation
have that it began with,
versus what did it perceive?
Because, I mean, the
other robots are moving.
And in the real
world, they might not
move as you predict them to be.
How did the blue robot
actually know for each step
where the robots were?
ALAN WINFIELD: Sure.
That's a very good question.
In fact we cheated,
in the sense that we
used-- for the real
robot experiments,
we used a tracking system.
Which means that essentially
the robot with an internal model
has access to the position.
It's like a GPS,
internal GPS system.
But in a way, that's
really just a kind
of-- it's kind of cheating,
but even a robot with a vision
system would be able
to track all the robots
in its field of vision.
And as for the second
part of your question,
our kind of model of what
the other robot that would do
is very simple.
Which is it's kind
of a ballistic model.
Which is if a robot is
moving at a particular speed
in a particular
direction, then we
assume it will continue to
do so until it encounters
an obstacle.
So very simple kind
of ballistic model.
Which even for humans is useful
for very simple behaviors,
like moving in a crowded space.
Oh hi.
AUDIENCE: In the
same experiment--
it's a continuation of
the previous question.
So in between some of
the red robots, how
changed their direction
randomly-- I guess so.
Does the internal model of
the blue robot consider that?
ALAN WINFIELD: Not explicitly.
But it does in the
sense that because it's
pre- or re-initializing it's
internal model every half
a second, then if the positions
and directions of the actors
in its environment
are changed, then they
will reflect the new positions.
So--
AUDIENCE: Not exactly
the positions.
But as you said, you have
considered the ballistic motion
of the objects.
So if there is any randomness
in the environment-- so
does the internal
model of the blue robot
consider the
randomness, and change
the view of the red robots?
It's like it views the red
robot as a ballistic motion.
So does it change its
view of the red robot
that red robots more in
the ballistic motion?
ALAN WINFIELD: Well, it's
a very good question.
I think the answer is no.
I think we're probably assuming
a more or less deterministic
model of the world.
Deterministic, yes, I think
pretty much deterministic.
But we're relying
on the fact that we
are updating and
rerunning the model,
reinitializing and rerunning
the model every half a second,
to, if you like, track
the stochasticity which is
inevitable in the real world.
We probably do need to
introduce some stochasticity
into the internal model, yes.
But not yet.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ALAN WINFIELD: But
very good question.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
With real life applications
with this technology,
like driverless
cars, for example,
I think it becomes a lot more
important how you program
the robots in terms of ethics.
So I mean, there could be
dilemma like if the robot has
a choice between saving
a school bus full of kids
versus one driver, that logic
needs to be programmed, right?
And you made a distinction
between being an engineer
yourself and then had
been an ethicist earlier.
So to what extent
is the engineer
responsible in that case?
And also does a project
like this in real life
always require the ethicist?
How do you see this field
in real life applications
evolving?
ALAN WINFIELD: Sure.
That's a really great question.
I mean, you're right that
driverless cars will-- well,
it's debatable whether they will
have to make such decisions.
But many people think they will
Which are kind of the driverless
car equivalent of the trolley
problem, which is a well-known
kind of ethical dilemma thought
experiment.
Now my view is
that the rules will
need to be decided not by the
engineers, but if you like,
by the whole of society.
So ultimately, the
rules that decide
how the driverless
car should behave
under these difficult
circumstances, impossible,
in fact,
circumstances-- and even
if we should, in fact, program
those rules into the car.
So some people argue that the
driverless cars should not
attempt to, as it were,
make a rule driven decision.
But just leave it to chance.
And again, I think
that's an open question.
But this is really why I
think this dialogue and debate
and conversations with
regulators, lawyers, ethicists,
and the general public,
users of driverless cars,
I think is why we need
to have this debate.
Because whatever those
rules are, and even
whether we have them
or not, is something
that should be decided,
as it were, collectively.
I mean, someone
asked me last week,
should you be able to alter the
ethics of your own driverless
car?
My answer is absolutely not.
I mean, that should be illegal.
So I think that if
driverless cars were
to have a set of
rules, and especially
if those rules had numbers
associated with them.
I mean, let's think of
a less emotive example.
Imagine a driverless car and
an animal runs into the road.
Well, , the driverless car
can either ignore the animal
and definitely kill the animal,
or it could try and brake,
possibly causing harm to the
driver or the passengers.
But effectively
reducing the probability
of killing the animal.
So there's an example
where you have some numbers
to tweak if you
like, parameters.
So if these rules are
built into driverless cars,
they'll be parameterized.
And I think it
should be absolutely
illegal to hack those
parameters, to change them.
In the same way that it's
probably illegal right now
to hack an aircraft autopilot.
I suspect that
probably is illegal.
If it isn't, it should be.
So I think that you
don't need to go
far down this line of
argument before realizing
that the regulation
and legislation has
to come into play.
In fact, I saw a piece in
just this morning in Wired
that, I think, in the US,
regulation for driverless cars
is now on the table.
Which is absolutely right.
I mean, we need to have
regulatory framework,
or what I call governance
frameworks for driverless cars.
And in fact, lots of
other autonomous systems.
Not just driverless cars.
But great question, thank you.
AUDIENCE: In the experiment
with the corridor,
you always assume-- even in the
other experiments-- you always
assume that the main actor
is the most intelligent
and the others are not.
Like they're dumb,
or like they're
ballistic models
or linear models.
Have you tried doing
a similar experiment
in which still each actor
is intelligent but assumes
that the others are not,
but actually everyone
is intelligent?
So like everyone is a
blue dot in the experiment
with the model that you have.
And also, have you considered
changing the model so that he
assumes that the others
have the same model
that that particular
actor has, as well.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ALAN WINFIELD: No, we're
doing it right now.
So we're doing that
experiment right now.
And if you ask me
back in a year,
perhaps I can tell you what
happ-- I mean, it's really mad.
But it does take us
down this direction
of artificial theory of mind.
So if you have several
robots or actors,
each of which is modeling
the behavior of the other,
then you get-- I
mean, some of the--
I don't even have a
movie to show you.
But in simulation
we've tried this
where we have two robots which
are kind of like-- imagine,
this happens to all of
us, you're walking down
the pavement and you do
the sort of sidestep dance
with someone who's
coming towards you.
And so the research
question that we're
asking ourselves is do
we get the same thing.
And it seems to be that we do.
So if the robots are
symmetrical, in other words,
they're each modeling
the other, then
we can get these kind of little
interesting dances, where each
is trying to get out of the
way of the other, but in fact,
choosing in a
sense the opposite.
So one chooses to step right,
the other chooses to step left,
and they still can't
go past each other.
But it's hugely interesting.
Yes, hugely interesting.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I think it's really
interesting how
you point out the
importance of simulations
and internal models.
But I feel that one thing
that is slightly left out
there is a huge gap from going
from simulation to real world
robots, for example.
And I assume that
in these simulations
you kind of assume that the
sensors are 100% reliable.
And that's obviously
not the case in reality.
And especially if we're talking
about autonomous cars or robots
and safety.
How do you calculate
the uncertainty
that comes with the
sensors in the equation?
ALAN WINFIELD: Sure.
I mean, this is a deeply
interesting question.
And the short answer
is I don't know.
I mean, this is all future work.
I mean, my instinct
is that a robot
with a simulation,
internal simulation,
even if that simulation
in a sense is idealized,
is still probably going to be
safer than a robot that has
no internal simulation at all.
And you know, I think we humans
have multiple simulations
running all the time.
So I think we have sort of quick
and dirty, kind of low fidelity
simulations when we
need to move fast.
But clearly when you need
to plan something, plan
some complicated
action, like where
you are going to go
on holiday next year,
you clearly don't use the same
internal model, same simulation
as for when you try
and stop someone
from running into the road.
So I think that future
intelligent robots
will need also to have
multiple simulators.
And also strategies
for choosing which
fidelity simulator to
use at a particular time.
And if a particular
situation requires
that you need high
fidelity, then for instance,
one of the things
that you could do,
which actually I think
humans probably do,
is that you simply move more
slowly to give your self time.
Or even stop to
give yourself time
to figure out what's going on.
And in a sense,
plan your strategy.
So I think even with the
computational power we have,
there will still be a
limited simulation budget.
And I suspect that
that simulation budget
will mean that in
real time, when you're
doing this in real time, you
probably can't run your highest
fidelity simulator.
And taking into account all
of those probabilistic, noisy
sensors and actuators
and so on, you probably
can't run that
simulator all the time.
So I think we're
going to have to have
a nuanced approach where we
have perhaps multiple simulators
with multiple fidelities.
Or maybe a sort of
tuning, where you can tune
the fidelity of your simulator.
So this is kind of a
new area of research.
I don't know anybody who's
thinking about this yet, apart
from ourselves.
So great.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ALAN WINFIELD: It
is pretty hard, yes.
Please.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ALAN WINFIELD: Do you
want the microphone?
Sorry.
AUDIENCE: Have you considered
this particular situation
where there are
two Asimov robots--
and that would be an extension
of the question that he asked.
So for example, if there
are two guys walking
on a pavement and there
could be a possibility
of mutual cooperation.
As in one might communicate
whether that I might step out
of this place and you might go.
And then I'll go after that.
So if there are
two Asimov robots,
will there be a
possibility, and have
you considered this fact
that both will communicate
with each other, and they will
eventually come to a conclusion
that I will probably walk,
and the other will get out
of the way.
And the second part
of this question
would be what if
one of the robots
actually does not
agree to cooperate?
I mean, since they both would
have different simulators.
They could have
different simulators.
And one might actually try to
communicate that you step out
of the way so that I might go.
And the other one
doesn't agree with that.
I mean, what would
the [INAUDIBLE].
ALAN WINFIELD: Yeah,
it's a good question.
In fact, we've actually
gotten a new paper which
we're just writing right now.
And the sort of working
title is "The Dark Side
of Ethical Robots."
And one of the things that we
discovered-- it's actually not
surprising-- is that you only
need to change one line of code
for a co-operative robot to
become a competitive robot,
or even an aggressive robot.
So it's fairly obvious, when
you start to think about it,
if your ethical rules
are very simply written,
and are a kind of
layer, if you like,
on top of the rest
of the architecture,
then it's not that difficult
to change those rules.
And yes, we've done
some experiments.
And again, I don't have
any videos to show you.
But they're pretty
interesting, showing
how easy it is to make a
competitive robot, or even
an aggressive robot
using this approach.
In fact, on the BBC
six months ago or so,
I was asked surely if you
can make an ethical robot,
doesn't that mean you can
make an unethical robot?
And the answer,
I'm afraid, is yes.
It does mean that.
But this really goes back
to your question earlier,
which is that it should
be-- we should make
sure it's illegal
to convert, to turn,
if you like, to recode
an ethical robot
as an unethical robot.
Or even it should be illegal
to make unethical robots.
Something like that.
But it's a great question.
And short answer, yes.
And yes, we have some
interesting new results,
new paper on, as it
were, unethical robots.
Yeah.
HOST: All right, we are
running out of time now.
Thanks everyone
for coming today.
Thanks, Professor Alan Winfield.
ALAN WINFIELD: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]